하지만 지금 고급 주택들이 계속 이제
신고가를 찍고 있는데 그 이윤 즉슨
[음악]
보면 안녕하세요 캐스트 김지 있니다
오늘은 저희 bsn 팬트 팀 김윤은
팀장님과 함께합니다 안녕하세요
팀장님네 안녕하세요 팀장님 간단히
자기소개 한번
부탁드리겠습니다네 저는 남에서
고급주택을 당하고 는 김은 팀장입니다
혹시 팀장님 공인중개사 하시기 전에
다른 일을 하셨었나요 어 그럼요 저는
공인중개사를 30대에 시작을
했어요네 그래서 20대 회사 생활하고
또 해외 경험도 몇 년 하고 그리고
한국에 와서 아 뭘 하면 좋을까
고민을 하다가 부동산 업계에서 한번
일을 해보고 싶다는 생각으로 봉인중
계사를 준비했습니다 전에 많은 일을
하시다가 공인중개사 일을 한번
해봐야겠다고 마음을 먹게 되신 개기
가 따로 있을까요 제가 회사 생활할
때는 경영관리 쪽에서 또 계약서를
많이 검토하는 법무 심사 팀이
있었어요 그래서 조금 익숙하기도
했었고 해외에서는 제가 유학 이민
회사를 또 운영을 했었는데 그것도
사람들 만나는 일이다 보니까는 어떻게
보면 영업직이 아아 그게 접목할 수
있는게 뭘까 생각을 하다가 공인
중개사를 생각을 했던 거 같아요 뭐
요즘 팬트 팀이 굉장히 바빠 보이는
거 같은데 요즘 어떤 업무를 주로
하고 계시는지 궁금합니다 아 저희는
고급주택 팀이 빌사남 생긴지가 이제
2년이 됐어요 그 전에는 제가 빌딩
중계를 하다가 그러다가 이제 고급주택
팀을 만들어서 한 건데 그러다 보니까
아직까지도 저희 팀을 알리는 일을 좀
많이 하고 있고요 직원분들 같은
경우에는 매물 확보해도 좀 집중 많이
하고 있어요 요즘 해외부동산 투자에
관심 있는 분들도 굉장히 많으신 거
같은데 팬트 팀에서 그런 것도 같이
관리를 해 주시나요네 저희 자산가
고객분들께서 해외에 또 물건을 가지고
계시거나 또 투자를 하시고 싶어
하시는 분들이 좀 꽤 대세요 그래서
최근 같은 경우에는 도쿄 미국의 뉴욕
같은데 투자를 원하시는 분들이 많으셔
가지고 최근에 또 저희 회사에서
세미나를 했었죠 그때 반응도 되게
좋으셨고 또 실 거주를 위해서 가시는
분들도 계셔 가지고 요즘 많이 집중을
하고 있어요 아요 열심히 일을 하시고
계시네요 핸드 주거 상품 투자를
고려하시는 분들은 어떤 목적으로
투자를 좀 고려하시는 이제가
궁금한데요 저희가 작년에 또 거래를
했던 몇백억대 주택 같은 경우는
투자보다는 이제 실거주 목적으로
보시는 분들이 많으세요 빌딩 같은
경우도 시세 차액으로 보실지
수익형으로 가실지 따라서 달라지는
것처럼 저희 주택도 실거주를 위한
주택인지 투자를 위한 주택인지 따라서
투자하시는 상품이죠 좀 많이 달라져요
고객분들께서는 많은 조건 같은게 있을
텐데 주 어떤 조건을 우선시 하여서
검토를 하시는지 좀 궁금한데요 일단은
본인이 어디에 거주하고 싶은지 지역이
있을 거고요 그리고 빌딩과 마찬가지로
또 금액대에 따라서 갈 수 있는
주택이 있다 보니까네 금액에 따라서도
조건이 많이 달라지는 거 같아요 실
거주가 목적이신 분들이 주로 투자를
고려를 하신다는 말씀이신 거죠 최근에
많이 생기고 있는 퍼 드라고 해가지고
2 300억대 이런 주택들이 많이
나오잖아요 이런 상품들 같은 경우는
투자 목적보다는 본인들이 실
거주하려는 목적이 또 많으세요 그리고
뭐 중소형 하이엔드 오피스텔 예를
들어 2 30억대 이런 오피스텔 같은
경우는 투자 목적으로 많이 보시고
그리고 임차 수익을 좀 받으시려는
경향이 있으시죠 금액이나 상품성에
따라 투자 목적이 굉장히 다양하다는
말씀이신 거죠 제가 뉴스 기사를 보다
보면
계속해서 고급주택 하이핸드 주거
상품들의 최고가가 갱신된다는 기사들을
되게 많이 봤어요 그럼 팀장님이
생각하시기에 그런 상품들의 가격이
리미트가 없이 계속 상승할 것
같으신지요 최근에 입주를 시작한
에테르노 청담을 보더라도 200억
정도의 거래가 됐어요 200억
수준이라고 하면은 2 3년 뒤에
300억 400억에 팔아 수 있을까
생각하면은 그건 아무도 장담을
못하겠죠 장도
마찬가지잖아요 하지만 지금 고급
주택들이 계속 이제 신고가를 찍고
있는데 그 이유 직은 보면 대체할
상품이 없다는 건 거 같아요 그래서
집이 주는 의미를 생각을 하다 보면은
본인에게 이만큼 가치가 있는지에
따라서 그만큼 금액을 투자를 하는지
안 하는지이기 때문에 어 리미팅
당연히 있겠지만 그래도 계속 상향을
하고 있는 거 같습니다 그러면 이건
조금 개인적으로도 좀 궁금한
질문인데요 팀 님께서 어떤 상품이든
다 매입하실 수 있다면 어떤 상품을
매입하실 것 같으신지요
저는 개인적으로 주거용은 아니지만은
시그니 레지던스를 되게 자주
올리잖아요 좋아하기도 하고 한 1
2년 정도는 시그니 레지던스에서
업무용으로 한번 입주를 해 보고
최종적으로는 저는 성수동의 아크로서울
프레스트 한번 살아보고 싶어요 혹시
이유가 따로 있을까요 시그 레지던스는
제일 좋은 뷰가 한강뷰 정도인데
아크로 서울 포레스트에서는 한강도 볼
수 있는데 그 넓은 서울숲을 같이 볼
수 있는 것도 정말 큰 메리트인 거
같아요 그래서 뷰 하나 보고 저는 그
값이 있다고 생각을 합니다 아네
알겠습니다 그러면 이제 마지막 그
파트로 달려가고 있는데요
팀장님께서는 어떤 마음가짐으로 중계를
하시는지 여쭤보고 싶습니다 저희가
고급 주택을 거래를 할 때는 는
당연히 고객분들의 큰 자산이
들어가는만큼 저희가이 집에 거주를
한다면 어떨까이 집에 이만큼 금액을
투자를 하면 어떨까 하는 생각으로
많이 고민을 하면서 중계를 하고
있고요 앞으로도 지금 상품이 계속
개발돼서 나오는 몇백억 대의 주택들이
있기 때문에 그만큼 고민은 더
깊어지지 않을까 싶어요 씨도 이제
빌딩 팀에서 계약을 계속 하시면
하실수록 금액이 점점 커지는 금액
대들도 있잖아요 정말 많은 금액을
고급 주택에 투자를 하시 는만큼 많이
고민을 해서 중계를 해 드려야 되지
않을까 고민을 하고 있습니다네 맞아요
한주 분하는 금액이 아니다 보니네
저도 굉장히 동감하는 부분입니다
그렇다면 공인중개사 김윤서 목표가
있을까요 저는 올해 좀 다양한
주택들을 거래를 많이 해보고 싶고요
올해 말까지는 뉴욕에도 한번 가보고
중계를 해보고 싶은 목표가 있습니다
아 해외 쪽으로 시장을 조금 더
넓히신 목표를 가지고 계시는 거죠네
그러면 마지막으로 bsn 팬드 팀을
어필할 기회를 드리겠습니다 저희
빌사남의 빌딩 중계만 하는 곳으로
많이 알고 들 계실 텐데요 지금 몇
10억부터 몇백억 대까지의 고급
스택도 거래를 하고 있는 bsn 펜트
팀이 있다는 것도 알아 주시고요 저희
펜트 팀에서 이렇게 레터가 나와요
여기에는 이제 해외 상품들이나 저희
한국에서 거래하고 있는 고급 주택들이
많이 나오고 있는데이 정보 원하시는
분들은 따로 연락 주시면은 저희가 또
레터 보내드리도록 하겠습니다네
하이엔드 주거 상품 투자 고려하시는
분들은 저희 윤은 팀장님께서 많은
도움 주실 수 있을 것 같습니다
오늘은 미모와 능력 모두 겸비하신
저희 bsn 팬트 팀 김윤은 팀장님과
함께했는데요 오늘 영상도 즐겁고
유익하셨다면 오늘 영상 여기서
마치겠습니다 감사합니다
감사합니다 UN